[Music]  there are things that batman needs to be  my job is to keep things the same in  some regards and then also to push  people out of their comfort zone having  him be younger having him have those  skills you know that that's my favorite  kind of batman a batman who is still  figuring it out who is batman what's to  stop somebody else from doing that and  taking that symbol and distorting the  meaning of it it's still a hit list that  you look at it and you go  that could be batman doing that  the whole thing was around how can i  make this feel  really wickedly real let the character  go to war with himself and also let him  go to war with a physical manifestation  of him  andrea sorrentino he's a wizard it takes  a lot to draw batman and i find the  human drama of just people talking in  rooms to be just as compelling  hopefully when people are reading this  book they're at a point where they go i  actually don't know if he's gonna be  okay  [Music]  you